that's pretty amazing and on er i gotta
ask i mean did you even work with george
clooney
yeah you did
the most amazing human being
how long every time you mention his name
or
like or i see him on something i i just
smile i'm just so happy for that man he
is truly
one of the nicest superstars
in the world nicest guy he doesn't even
have to be a superstar what was it about
him like when you're on set what do you
recall that you just remember him so
vividly being so kind and nice what was
it about him
everything i mean he is always just
i remember
i remember i had to do the tonight show
and he was also a guest you know and you
know how like because he's the bigger
star they always have the biggest star
first and then they leave right
well i was like ready to piss in my
pants i was so nervous because
i you know i'm really more an introvert
i thought i was an extrovert but i'm
really not
and so when this kind of stuff happens
i
i get very nervous and so my publicist
he apparently like knocked on george's
door
and told him that i was really really
nervous and was about to like just throw
up and not go on
and so george knowing that
he stayed
instead of leaving
like when like he stayed
the whole time on that set with me
just in case i
you know like he was just
he stayed in the chair he didn't leave
as the lead guest yes on the tonight
show
you know just like little subtle things
like that that
and he's done a million other like on
set he's just do you remember him being
hunky on set
sure
but i think he's hunkier now you like
the older george i think so yeah you do
yeah yeah i mean he was he was he was
hot back then too